piqûre de rappel ce mercredi en
préfecture de Versailles les délégués du
Défenseur des droits ont expliqué à la
presse le rôle de leur institution créer
il y a un peu plus d'un an et qui
rassemble les compétences auparavant
confient au médiateurs de la République
au défenseurs des droits des enfants à
la Commission nationale de déontologie
de la sécurité et à la Haute autorité de
lutte contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité le défenseur droit c'est
effectivement
un médiateur et quelqu'un qui est qui
aide les gens à faire rétablir leurs
droits
c'est quelqu'un qui aide à
décrypter la société puisque au fond les
athées droits viennent de blocage de la
société donc c'est un c'est un une
institution qui sert à préserver la
cohésion sociale et ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le pacte républicain
l'institution est encore jeune très peu
de chiffres ont été publiés à propos de
son action à l'échelle nationale on peut
noter que près de 80 000 dossiers de
médiation avec les services publics ont
à déposer auprès du Défenseur des droits
plus de 2200 dossiers ont été traités
dans le cadre de sa mission de défense
des enfants et un peu plus de 8000
réclamations ont été reçues à propos de
discriminations localement Louis
trujillot se félicite de l'influence
positive du Défenseur des droits sur la
préfecture 2 Versailles cette dernière
aurait en effet revu son mode de
traitement des demandes de titres de
séjour suite au grand nombre de plaintes
déposés par des étrangers lésés par la
lenteur des procédures administratives
pour information sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin les délégués du Défenseur
des droits sont basés attrapes
aiguillancourt